I am a fan of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and I feel like I should
preface this video by saying that
because this is not going to be a video
where I just hammer on the MCU for a
while and then call it a day and in fact
I've been a fan of Marvel Comics since I
was a little kid X-Men the Animated
Series is really what got me into it all
and I picked up their comic books and
have been reading ever since
but as much as I love Marvel Comics and
as much as I love the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
I did not love phase four
and so in this video what I want to do
is I want to talk about where I think
phase four went wrong
and I want to talk about what they could
do not so much to fix it since it's
already done
but what they can do in the future of
the MCU
to make sure they don't run into this
problem again
[Music]
so first things first the success of the
mcu's first three phases came from
following a literary principle called
the hero's journey this process
functions as a kind of circle the hero
lives in an Ordinary World they receive
a call to Adventure they initially
refuse the call but change their minds
after which they meet their Mentor
following this they cross the threshold
meaning they're now committed to their
task along the way they face some
threats both minor and life-threatening
they approach What's called the
innermost cave also known as the
location of the treasure they seize the
treasure they start the journey home and
they find themselves being reborn
through the Journey they'd undertaken
now looking at the MCU both the
individual characters and the larger
franchise experience this journey on a
broad scale The Ordinary World is a
world with superpowered beings this is
best Illustrated in Iron Man 1's
post-credits scene when Nick Fury visits
Tony Stark and says that he stepped into
a much larger world the same can said
when Captain America wakes up after 70
years when Black Widow brings Mark
ruffalo's Hulk back to the field or when
Thor cannot lift his hammer
Adventure is of course Nick Fury's
Avengers Initiative and the refusal of
the call is best highlighted when Mark
Ruffalo questions whether or not the
Avengers can even function as a team and
the first Avengers film now meeting
their Mentor doesn't really happen in
the traditional sense because there's no
giant training montage where the group
is taught to fight in a conventional way
instead this is found more through the
Captain America's wisdom for becoming
more humble Wanda seeing Ultron for who
he is and stuff like that the Avengers
kind of become their own mentors if
we're being honest although I guess a
case could be made here for Phil Coulson
although I always felt like he was more
of a mascot than a mentor now the
threats they face come from within and
without and they range from Loki's
initial Invasion and Avengers 1 Iron Man
and banner secretly creating Ultron and
Avengers 2 Bucky Barnes being blamed for
the death of t'chaka in Captain America
Civil War or Eric killmonger trying to
start a race war in black panther one
the innermost cave and the Supreme
ordeal are reflected in Thanos both
acquiring and using the Infinity Stones
as well as the hero's time travel Antics
in retrieving the stones restoring those
who were snapped and of course the
journey home is each of the characters
dealing with the aftermath to Avengers
in-game in their own way but the ability
to follow this story on both the
individual and macro level that's what
kept us coming back
we wanted to see the world through
Captain America's eyes 70 years removed
from the life he'd known would he be
able to make it in the Modern Age we
wanted to experience new places like
wakanda and we were able to identify
with Wanda's pain from losing the things
that mattered most to her because at
some point in our lives we've all been
down that road before so before we
continue with this video we do want to
say thank you to our sponsor Atlas VPN
and right now you can get a steal of a
Black Friday deal because now you can
get atlas VPN premium for just a buck 70
a month plus six months extra with a
30-day money-back guarantee and it's the
best Atlas VPN offer of the year so make
sure you guys are quick and make sure
you get your deal by clicking on the
link in the video description because
it's a limited time offer but for those
of you guys who don't use a VPN these
things are dead useful and I love using
Atlas VPN because it's so affordable but
one of the great things about a VPN is
like Geo restriction as a lot of you
guys know different companies out there
will only allow certain parts of the
world to access different types of
content and if you're an American that
decides to travel abroad to some place
like London and you can't access
American content using Atlas VPN will
make that entirely possible for you now
this also comes with other benefits like
being able to block malware being able
to hide your VPN from other services and
is insanely cool because it actually
keeps companies from tracking you which
is really one of the better things so
again with the Black Friday deal they're
running you can get atlas VPN premium
for just a buck 70 a month plus six
months extra with a 30 day money back
guarantee and again it's the best Atlas
VPN offer of the year so make sure you
guys are quick and get your deal by
clicking the link below inside the video
description because it really is a
limited time offer but with that being
said guys let's get back into our video
the problem with phase four at least in
my mind is that on a franchise level
while the journey was over the MCU kept
moving forward in a way that assumed the
journey never ended despite in-game
concluding with a finality in fact I've
heard some compelling arguments about
how the MCU could have just shut its
doors following Avengers endgame and it
would have felt right and in fact I
agree with a lot of these arguments if
they shut down what Avengers end game
was done
it would have just felt natural
from where I'm sitting in phase four the
MCU wanted to introduce new characters
while simultaneously building into the
next series of events the problem with
this is a simple one it burns people out
living out the hero's journey analysis
the Simplicity of phases one through
three was that on a loose level phase
one gave us the good guy facing a
villain with similar Powers phase two
had the hero facing a villain from their
past and phase three had the hero facing
an arch nemesis now there are some
exceptions to this since origin films
were spread throughout all three phases
but the overall franchise was easy to
follow not only that we all knew where
the ending was headed but being on the
journey and seeing how they got there
that was half the excitement the thing
of it is all of this happened over the
course of 10 years on the other hand
when I look at shows like Hawkeye Moon
Knight and She-Hulk I see Marvel trying
to cram a main star their Supporting
Cast their Origins their motivations and
their powers into a six to nine episode
Arc to give you guys a frame of
reference for a lot of the characters
their Redemption Arc the things that
made them who they were their
motivations their powers and so on it
took multiple films to fully flesh that
out
films like eternals seem to focus more
on the Cinematic and serious tone of a
superhero film which is not a terrible
thing but it did this while having very
little substance which is a problem and
other projects like Loki Spider-Man no
way home and Doctor Strange too we're
trying to move the franchise forward it
just feels like too much and in some
cases it felt like quantity over quality
now that being said since I'm not Reddit
or Twitter I don't want to just complain
about a problem I want to offer a
solution to that problem and so about
halfway through phase four I started
thinking about this you know people
often ask how the MCU could top Avengers
end game but honestly I think that's the
wrong question asked
the question should not be how do we top
Avengers end game the question should be
how do we restart this journey
and get back to the feeling that came
with Avengers endgame
now keeping this relatively short I know
this is going to be controversial and
I'm sure some people are going to
disagree with it but I would not have
made any of the projects that we got in
phase four although I guess that's a
little bit of an overstatement Loki
Spider-Man no way home and Doctor
Strange 2 I would have pushed back to
phase five with Loki being the official
start of the Multiverse Saga everything
else gets the ax instead I would have
launched two shows in phase four Marvel
two in one and Marvel Spotlight
now Marvel two and one was a title that
Marvel used back in the 1970s and
technically it was a team-up comic but
we wouldn't really be doing any team up
stories instead it would be a mini
series that would run for one month with
a different episode each week and each
episode would be 30 minutes long with
two 15-minute segments segment one would
introduce a character and segment two
would do the same to give you some
perspective on what this would look like
imagine the scenes from werewolf by
night after they capture Jack Russell
and then put him in a cage everybody
comes in with torches talking about how
they hunt down and kill monsters
eventually Jack escapes kills pretty
much everybody and then takes off into
the woods
roll credits
another segment would introduce She-Hulk
in a similar fashion following this I
would just sit back and watch
the characters that people talk about
the most would continue to make
appearances in the MCU the others
wouldn't now maybe these appearances
would come in the form of a movie Cameo
or a cameo in another show but the
purpose of the series would be to
introduce a new character in such a way
that it's both easy to follow but teases
just enough to make the audience want
more
now moving beyond this
if model 2 and 1 gives us some fresh
faces what's the point of Marvel
Spotlight
well the reality here is that mobile
Spotlight would wrap up the plot threads
and answer some of our burning questions
from the projects that we've gotten so
far in this instance phases one through
three
what did Steve Rogers life with Peggy
Carter look like did he tell her Hydra
was secretly replacing Shield did they
have kids did he meet Captain Britton
Brian Braddock
find out in Marvel Spotlight Captain
America
what did Bruce Banner see in Avengers 2
Age of Ultron when Scarlet Witch messed
with his mind find out in Marvel
Spotlight The Incredible Hulk
what did it look like when Clint Barton
was running around killing villains as
Ronan in the five-year gap between
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers
endgame
find out in Marvel Spotlight Hawkeye now
I chose this route for a simple reason
if we treat the MCU like a relationship
and as anybody who's been around the
block a few times would tell you you
have to have something or a series of
things that give you a life outside of
your relationship this does two things
it helps you maintain your sense of self
but it also gives you a chance to miss
each other the second is what applies
the most here honestly the MCU hasn't
given us a chance to miss them and the
post Avengers in-game landscape was the
perfect time to do that
again I don't think that walking away
from producing content entirely is a
good idea and even then I doubt Disney
would actually let Marvel do that but
giving people just enough content to
remember you but not enough content to
feel burned out is key it's a delicate
Balancing Act and while phase four is
over I truly believe that this is a
strategy that would work for the future
of the MCU after every major event that
they launch which includes Kang Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars so what I want
to know from you guys is what do you
think of this plan is it one that you
agree with is it one that you think
would work or do you think it's just
crazy and Madness let me know down in
the comments and I will catch you all
later
peace